pleased to have here on the rich eisen
show one of the stars of the new film
coming out in a theater near you as well
as uh hbo max on november the 19th king
richard uh will smith plays uh richard
williams the father of venus and serena
williams and the man who plays the role
of rick macy
one of the more famous tennis coaches in
the history of the sport
is john bernthal here on the rich eisen
show how are you john
how you doing man i i really appreciate
you uh you have me on and i i agree you
know the gigolo show it is based on your
life man and that is why i have my
picture up on your wall while i was
shooting it man i was glad now that
whole thing makes sense wrong wrong
richard that's gear you're thinking of
not eisen wrong richard there you go
yeah i am an officer though and a
gentleman um there you go oddly enough
um so you're from d.c does that mean you
root for dc teams john i do i do uh uh
um
and that's uh that's not always the
easiest thing i mean uh
being a football team fan um you know
it's definitely been a struggle i i
think um you know right now i'm shooting
in baltimore
um so to see sort of like what the
ravens have done and and you know what
um
you know to to see what ozzie newsome
did with that team for so long and it
was it was quite tempting to sort of
abandon [ __ ] but i'm one of these guys i
i uh i believe that burgundy and gold
i'm not going to change and you know i
came up in you know 83 and 84 and 87 and
92 where we uh you know we won and
participated in super bowls with
different quarterbacks and i just i just
don't think that's really uh it's it's
it's just not really possible anymore
you spend time at quarterback you spend
time in rfk as a kid did you ever go oh
yeah oh yes
and and rk was a you know it's just such
a special place
to see a game you know dc is a really
interesting city it's it's um
you know it's like a northeastern city
with a very southern vibe and then
you've got virginia right there and um
you know maryland it's all kind of like
this conglomeration but i felt like rfk
was sort of the one place where everyone
really came together and the whole
stadium rocked and i missed those days
and i missed i missed that team with all
my heart so were you a nationals guy too
a couple of years ago when they went on
that ride
again i'm not a real bandwagon guy i
mean i love the nationals i i was
rooting for them but you know when i was
a kid we had the orioles so that you
know it was the days of brady anderson
and and um pomeroy you know i i grew up
an orioles fan so so you brady anderson
at palmeira you're also cursing uh the
uh umpire richie garcia calling the
jeffrey mayor home run that that's
that's that era is what you're saying
all that stuff okay but you're so you're
in baltimore now so that's good for you
at least you know you're you're around
the orioles even though they i think you
might have won more games playing
baseball this year than they did john
you know that's entirely possible it's
really easy to get a ticket man so it's
super fun to go to the stadium it's a
beautiful stadium it really is uh camden
yards so let's talk about king richard
um because i i was on sportscenter when
when richard williams was
saying uh about his daughters how
terrific they were and they were gonna
change the game
and i remember when serena uh first
started playing we're like okay she
she's not gonna be as good as venus and
he says she's going to be better and
we're all like oh okay you you have our
attention and then he was right then he
was right um so what did you learn about
this process going through all this
playing the tennis coach uh rick macy in
this look i mean i think i i think a lot
of people are going to walk into this
movie uh you know with a bunch of um
preconceptions that will prove to be
sort of misconceptions and i think we'll
sort of have this narrative about what i
i think there's something that goes with
sort of the the overbearing sports
parent um
that that we think that that that's just
this enormous amount of pressure this
sort of um unwillingness to um to sort
of uh bend and and to make sure you know
for lack of a better word just to always
be sort of uh you know kind of having
you know just pushing the kid forward
pushing the kids forward making sure
they reach their goals i think people
are going to be really surprised when
they really see sort of what kind of his
plan and what his method was and
and most of it was really
removing the pressure that he puts on
his kids and and and making the game fun
for them um
i i think the movie kind of ultimately
is this beautiful sort of meditation on
fatherhood and on family and on faith um
i uh i i i think it's uh i'm really
proud of this one i don't say that all
the time with the movies that i'm in um
i think what will does and what what
what these uh two young women do um is
is staggering and look for me at the
sport you know i played sports in
college i grew up playing sports never
played tennis before but getting sort of
the mindset of um you know a tennis
coach you know i trained extensively uh
they let me train my own um
you know top 50 junior uh uh uh women's
uh tennis player uh to sort of like
learn the vocabulary of of coaching and
uh you know i i learned a ton about the
sport and just how unbelievably mental
it is and i came away having a ton of
respect for it and um a ton of respect
for the williams as a family uh you know
in in a new way in a new way and i think
look i i think raising sort of you know
one
superstar
best athlete of all time is miraculous
but but doing it twice
i mean there's like no words for it and
and uh i think you really see sort of
the
you you get a front row ticket to sort
of seeing what the process was there and
this is not just like sort of a
highlight reel of the great moments of
the williams sisters lives it's really
about the family and how the family kind
of got them there and how it was really
this collective familial effort and i
think it's pretty beautiful so you you
coached a top 50 player is that is that
why emma radekano won the us open
because we were wondering how she got
that is that was that you john is that
what you're doing
you know yeah you know it was more look
the guy who made the film ronaldo marcus
green he's a awesome director he and i
connected immediately look we both
played college baseball we both come at
this whole thing from athletics and we
really it's important to us that you
know you make a movie about a sport you
got to get the sport right and for me
you know admittedly not knowing anything
about tennis i said the only way this is
gonna work is i gotta lose a ton of
weight i gotta look like a tennis player
and then i gotta really learn the game
and and what was really great when i'm
super grateful to him and sort of for
warner brothers in general for doing is
they they didn't only provide me the
infrastructure to learn the game but
they learned they they let me learn how
to train someone again the vocabulary of
that how you train how you feed
different drills and you know the way
that these folks at the wheel tennis
center in ohio california trained me is
they let me actually work with one of
their players and uh it was great i got
to go see her compete um i got to train
her myself it was uh it was awesome and
uh now i'm uh i'm i'm taking that on to
my to my youngsters so it's emma
radicanu right that's who it was i mean
just say it john it's okay if you if you
coached her up like that i mean oh man i
signed an nda man okay very good uh all
right uh so uh were any of the williams
family uh around like did will smith
pick the brains of uh richard williams
and uh were serena and venus any part of
this at all
they were they were you know um the
the uh their sister isha was on set
every single day and she's a producer
and she was enormously helpful and that
that's one of the other things you're
going to find out about this family and
and all of the sisters they were all
they all are extraordinarily talented
and successful in in their paths and
that was sort of one of richard
williams's rules i mean there was no
tennis unless the grades were perfect
and there was no you had to go to church
you had to
you you had to do your chores you had it
wasn't just sort of tennis over
everything it was uh how is tennis going
to serve you not how are you going to
serve tennis um and then serena and
venus they were around they did come to
set um you know i had a wonderful
conversation with serena you know right
off the jump just talking about rick
macy and talking about you know i think
look again as an athlete you know i
credit so much of my success and my
happiness my peace of mind to the
wonderful coaches that i had coming up
and i was trying to think you know what
what makes a coach great i think you
know rick macy what everyone says about
him who played under him sort of to a
person they just made the game fun
everything was a game he was larger than
life you always want to keep you
laughing always want to keep you happy
and um you know
to remember that the game needs to be
fun and um serena said that you know her
time at
rick macy's was one of the funnest times
of her life and so i really try to take
that to heart yeah he coached radek and
capriati and also uh uh sharapova
sharapova um so um it's you know and so
did you reach out to him as well did you
connect with me
we did we spoke and you know he's got a
book and a ton of stuff on the internet
he's going to be at the premiere this
weekend i can't wait to
shake his hand and meet him in person
but he's real happy with the movie and
look he's uh he's an interesting
character man he's got his own
vocabulary he's uh he he's got these
things called macyisms uh you know uh
let's put a little more mustard on that
hot dog and uh find the slot rip the
shot that kind of stuff and he's he's
constantly sort of doesn't mind being
kind of the butt of the joke just as
long as that's getting you to play
harder and i really respect that he's
got this pure pure love for the game and
i think that's that's why ultimately
sort of richard williams let him fit
into the sort of overall plan and and
eventually hire him and then move to
florida to go live on his you you know
and be a part of that academy and uh you
know i think these are two guys that
really were used to doing things their
way and um you know the compromise that
that that rick sort of had to take in
order to work with richard um i think
that that calls for some of the most
interesting stuff in this film okay are
you a servant volley guy john or are you
what are you uh are you uh uh like a
magician uh like uh
what are you like let my sheer
athleticism you know win the day you
know what i mean you get gritted out you
got to tough it out you know those five
setters that's that's how you that's how
you survive all right so this would be
great again king richard available in
theaters uh on november 19th also on hbo
max
john gimmer give me right now please for
everybody here the best wolf of wall
street behind the scenes story that you
can tell anybody on live television and
radio please oh man the best what are
you going to do
scorsese leo what do you got for me
anything mcconaughey if you're around
any of those scenes um
i mean i think i think i think my my my
favorite story my favorite wolf wall
street story is that whole thing with uh
sell me this pen you know that that
whole thing with the supply and demand
and and uh you know where that came from
leo was walking to set that day with his
security guard who was a retired new
york city detective and he had turned to
leo and he said you know back in the day
i had an interview to work for the real
wolf of wall street for jordan belfort i
walked into the interview and all he did
is he handed me a pence to sell me this
pen so in that scene leo just walked in
and completely improvised he just handed
me the pen to sell me this pen and the
rest of it was improvised and the thing
is is you know that um
it was that sort of that that entire
movie was just kind of electric you know
working with scorsese i mean i imagine
it's it's um
you know like like with belichick and is
it like with any of these guys it's it's
it's
you know it's the best the best it's the
mountaintop and and somehow
he's able to literally get the best out
of every single person on set and um i
think it's a lesson for all of us no
matter what business you're in you know
he really he takes the leash off and
lets everybody fly and uh you know i
literally i could tell you a story
pretty much about every day some of
those things i probably shouldn't tell
you but there's things i could tell you
pretty much about every day on that set
that would uh it was it was it was
electric and it was alive and the way
film should be made all right is there
something that couldn't make it even
scorsese said that's too much anything
like that
no um
you know we were really you know i'll
tell you what you know leo talked to us
before that movie was made and you know
he i remember he's uh you know he's such
an unbelievable leader and you know he
said to us before we start shooting he
said look this kind of movie will not be
able to be made in five years this is
the last time
and like he did he had that foresight
he's like you just won't so i am asking
you all to push the envelope like
just go for it whatever depraved sick
thought you have in your mind go for it
he's like that's what this is about and
uh you know he's absolutely right you
couldn't make that movie now and it's a
masterpiece and so i mean look crazy
things happened every day some things
made it in some things made it it didn't
um but i can tell you every single day
there was uh
you know look a lot of naked bodies a
lot of a lot of you know pretend
debauchery and uh you know a lot of just
pushing the envelope but you know like
that's that's that's what the movie
called for that might be the name of our
fantasy team please write down chris
brockman we need we do this all the time
pretend debauchery would be a great
fantasy team name
pretend debauchery and we know what the
avatar is it's john bernthal and wolf of
wall street that'll be fantastic
there's so many other uh of your um
credits i could go for right now to ask
you about from sicario to you know uh
baby driver ford versus ferrari but john
it's very rare that i have somebody on
the show that has a similar credit
to me
uh john uh you and i share
the fact that we've both been in two
episodes of csi miami john um yeah
and uh i've been in two i didn't know
that was in two well i'll take it man
yes you were in we looked this up you
were in the episode you played harry
klugman no relation to jack i imagine
right um
okay
okay you play you you were in the the
the two episodes called vengeance and
killer date
that's what you're in um
i was in two episodes you might have
seen them or missed them uh caged
and deep freeze
i was in both of them um on one episode
i played announcer
and the other one interestingly enough i
got i guess upgraded or more descriptive
mail announcer i was in the other one
okay there you go um but i wasn't
helping solve crimes at all what's your
what's your what's your your best caruso
story you got a good one for me david
cruz you know i didn't really work with
him on that so i'm gonna fail you on
that one man i really don't you know i
can't you know on those shows you're
either the guy who's lying or you're the
guy who says who is lying you know what
i mean i can't even remember which one i
was on that you know
moved on you've moved on you've turned
the page from csi miami i haven't you
know i haven't hey man hey hey look man
not not at all i i'm i'm real grateful
for being on the show but really do not
remember
[Laughter]
what does it mean that i won't ever
forget it what does that mean for me
great man it's great mail announcer hey
listen man
the thing you got to go for is i for me
it was just always about getting a name
on that show i remember my very first
role i was stage manager on one life to
live and i do remember that and my lines
were and then five four three two and i
pointed at i could they didn't even give
me one i had to appoint it
you know like you know i i stage manager
but you know at least
i would have appreciated the mail stage
manager at the time so sure about that
and you could have ad lived and gone you
could have said the one but uh it was
your first gig and you probably just
wanted to stick to the script i get it
john thanks for the call man um
everybody should go see king richard in
theaters near you and on hbo max on
november 19th and you've got a ton of
upcoming stuff that american gigolo that
i mentioned prior to you coming on that
is a richard gere to the television
version of of that is that what it is or
or no yeah
literally man yeah it's based off that
you know obviously sort of modernized
and it kind of takes place after the the
the kind of the crime that's committed
um as you can imagine not the uh not
not the best thing to run by the the
wife and the kids when i told them that
was the new gig but
it's work john it's work you know it's
work fantastic and then the unforgivable
which is going to be on netflix with the
sandra bullock uh in december uh come
back then let's see what the wft looks
like then we'd love to ch uh chat again
john thanks for the call i appreciate it
thank you for your time guys i really
appreciate it right back at you that's
john bernthal or at johnny j-o-n-n-y
bernthal on twitter and instagram
right here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here